check one check one test one check one
check one check two
everybody say yay it's Jay and Silent
Bob hey man I'm Kevin Smith and not even
a pandemic can keep Jay and Silent Bob
apart we got our gloves one of us is
masked like maskatron and [ __ ] like that
we you know we were trying to figure out
what to do with our time and whatnot
first we'll check in and chitchat and
then I'll tell you I think what we
arrived at how have you been during this
quarantine sir and I asked not because
of you you're a house bug like myself
yes like we had just been on tour and
then Jason was separately by himself on
tour and Jason loves to stream and game
on his twitch channel what's your twitch
channel Jamie JY m ii w es twitch plug
plug so he loves doing that he was doing
that through the whole tour so the idea
of like you got to stay home right up
his alley like he ain't upset about that
one iota but and so could be a paradise
however he has the one factor that I
don't have in this house that you know
would would probably crash the idyllic
quarantine experience you got a five
year old yes it's been tough it's been
it's been amazing and tough at the same
time because do I sound alright with
this thing on my right it's it's been
amazing to get to sit and play with her
you know not being out of town I'd so
hard for me usually when I'm gone for a
week ten days but because she's used to
going to school yeah she's used to then
after school she has you know cooking
class one day a week she has a Spanish
class and different activities so she's
pretty busy and interacting with her
friends running around playing on the
playground so and even if she's not at
school I can bring her to the park down
the street and
you go on the slide into jungle-gym her
in the house
non-stop there are moments man she you
know under school there's still of
course we want him to still we want her
to keep doing schoolwork and they have
Wow why are you guys going through with
the you know [ __ ] false illusion of
like school man everything's collapsing
if I'm the kid I'm just like [ __ ] your
school old man it's just [ __ ] it's
it's it's pandemic rules well for one
it's not up to me on me it's up to the
boss but I'd leave the boss
my wife Jordan Monsanto me is but look I
would want her to continue like she has
three classes a day at 9:30 she does a
nine o'clock sir she does French with
her class there's like eight or nine of
them and the teachers on the computer
and there's little windows and all the
kids are in there then eleven she has
English where they you know read books
and Monday and spell out Saturday Monday
Tuesday I even have a little Jan that's
caught in my head from watching and
helping her out at eleven o'clock okay
these are the week days of the week days
of the week days of the week days of the
week Sunday end is Monday
there's Tuesday and there's Wednesday
this Thursday and the Friday and then
there Saturday these are the week anyway
taste that we just broke copyrights
right there shout out to the Adams
family what is that what they're
teaching in schools one of them yeah
that's one of the days of the week songs
that they sing and neighbor I hate to be
this cabbie you said your kids were in
private schools where they charge your
money right yeah that's what the
throwing of kids that make you pay and
they're like yo sing this song days
it'll week and it's only a part that's
what I'm saying there's it's a
copywriter there's nine there's nine
o'clock French class then there's ten
eleven o'clock English and then there's
circle time and there's also another
class he has like four classes where she
has to sit at the table at the computer
and watch video and there's days virtual
sit there and not get up days or days of
the week
days of the week she'll sit on Wednesday
Thursday so you know that's that
question the big question is what like
how bad does it get for a five-year-old
that she like I hate this I want to see
my friends I want to see my grandma then
she's like I love it I want to play with
this play with that then she'll like
literally like run around the house and
like she she goes through moments she's
definitely definitely and I don't just
say this she I see so many things
relatable to her being my kid and not
even cuz she sees me do stuff just the
things that I used to do like have these
bursts of energy and you know start
dancing booty booty booty booty booty
pop booty but you know like doing like
random things built an entire career off
that right there booty booty butt booty
pop booty [ __ ] she'll grab my wife's
phone and start texting or my phone and
start texting Kevin these emojis but she
loves she's like I want to text uncle
Kevin I want to Kevin anyway I enjoy
that but it's again it's it's so amazing
and at times it's overwhelming because
you're trying to clean the house the
wife gets overwhelmed and I get it I
feel like I'm dealing with it best and
you would think it wouldn't be the case
in the sense of dealing with like
moments of like oh my gosh I feel like
I've had one bad day where I really was
like well I'm really having trouble with
this today with the kid no just whatever
with the quarantine yeah because
remember I'm used to like you said I'm
used to
I miss the kid I miss the wife when I
leave yeah but I'm still used to having
those two days three days where I could
stay up til 2:00 in the morning sleep in
the 11 or if I want to do this or that
now it's like I'm woken up at 7:30 every
morning because the kid will run in and
open my eyeball and beg daddy daddy play
with me daddy play with me wake up
[ __ ] he's little weak so how
much more do you appreciate your kids
teacher right now I'm much appreciate my
Jordan more she's been like doing a lot
of stuff while her home I appreciate the
teachers
I appreciate my time
again I I always miss the kid in the
wife but I'm telling you I'm craving a
comic book convention right now it's
3:00 Friday series Sunday days away from
home it's staying in a hotel going to
Comic Cons and being like yo what's up
Japan stitch - The Dude's there - the
date you know but I do love the moments
where I get to stream I love streaming
but again that's even tough because I
don't want to spend five hours during
the day streaming where Jordan's inside
dealing with everything and I could play
games so I've been doing it at nighttime
when when the kids are sleeping and
stuff like that but then there's not a
lot of time you know not a lot of cuddle
time with the wife because she's putting
the kid to bed and I'm streaming and
then time I come in she's already asleep
and I'll try to like you know she's like
you're gonna have to hit me up on
another day of the week and I miss
seeing everybody man like again I even
miss walking to Starbucks I used to just
walk to Starbucks when I back I need to
get out I'd walk to Starbucks but it's
ago the Starbucks is closed I can still
walk there and look in the window but
what does that like because that's your
home away from home it is it's a bummer
it's a bummer luckily I've been
expressed kickin Oh cake pops can you
know egg bites the [ __ ] is wrong with
this world all your little routines have
been disrupted even coming here and
seeing you spending some time here with
you and these there's so many it's such
a weird I have these moments where I'm
just like this is you know cuz I think
I've been around pretty long 45 years
mm-hmm I see some [ __ ] yeah we've seen
some things do but there has been not
anything like this I really feel like
there's moments I wake up and go this is
gonna be like the Walking Dead - the
zombies but like why - the zombies
that'd be the best part that would be
cool but I'm just saying like I really
get nervous like give me - like - the
complete lack of [ __ ] government or
were [ __ ] the stores being closed
like zombies I could deal with as long
as we can still go to Target yeah we got
a target one of the stores get some like
nerf guns in the time of zombies so it's
it's been it's been a very interesting
few weeks but I'm I'm very excited to be
here because I've been thinking every
day what can I do what can Kevin and I
do for our streams well we could do a
number of things we're thinking about
playing one of our games a J and Samba
big fat card on game by a good folks at
place to him and where we might do that
not today but at a future time I think
what we'll do today is read a script you
know he's an actor
I've been around actors I play a quiet
character but in real life I'm very
chatty
I had a great morning great morning man
with a wonderful phone call that I think
moved a project that we're gonna be
working on ahead in a big wonderful way
so I was thinking we're not gonna read
that script and I'm not gonna tell you
what it is but what we can read is we
got remember we did a show called Holly
weed and we were trying to finance the
rest of the season through a company
called rivet tv.com which didn't turned
out to be quite a hot idea
so we shot an episode and at me and
Donnell Rawlings and it's on YouTube I
think it's still on YouTube I'm not sure
but anyway I had written other scripts
so I pulled the episode to a holly weed
scripts only 30 pages that's why I
didn't go with one of our movies because
that's like 90 pages of [ __ ] 30 pages
we're in and out man so I figured let's
read the [ __ ] script the show was
called Holly weed if you've not seen the
pilot on YouTube it was me and Donnell
running a weed store
Frankie Shaw came into our lives but
then in the end of it she [ __ ] took
off so this was episode
to be Episode two I'll read all the
narration and I'll play the part of Pete
which is the part I was playing Jay will
read Rollo that's his part the part he
played in the pilot but he'll also since
Donnell is not he'll read for Donal and
he'll read for the other for the female
league because there's a lot of
interplay between me and the female
character so you're gonna be tasked with
with a performance I know you did very
wonderful and Jay and Silent Bob reboot
now available on Amazon Prime watch that
[ __ ] for free and you know you just
stepped up in terms of performance
wonderful performance this performance
will require you to reach into your tap
your feminine side I don't mean that in
a dirty way you've got it you got a B
you got further for the audience be the
woman or else everyone's gonna be like I
think about to make out which is
something I think they've been saying
about us our entire [ __ ] careers so
yes you're gonna need to play it but not
like you can't go high up in the voice
falsetto and be like did you got it you
got a inhabit the role and to be like a
male actor trying to pull off female
actors which we would never do under any
other circumstances is gonna require all
of your acting [ __ ] talents 26 years
of acting professional acting ability
brought to the fore since you're gonna
be looking forward I would I'm not you
know the sounds unsafe but I would lower
your mask because you're not risking
you're gonna spit on your own computer
plus as far as we know yeah as far as we
know we're not sick you think you're
sick no I've been I mean I but we could
be carrying it for all except for a
couple times I went to the grocery store
in the last month okay but I
as soon as as soon as I stepped out of
the store I took all my stuff off
I wiped myself down with wipes and all
that so we're on can I do a quick post
up about guys after this anyone here we
I couldn't do we couldn't do the twitch
right now but when we're done here I'm
gonna move it right over to twitch so if
you want to continue a little music ssin
little game action you know we'll be
doing that later but don't worry about
that right now but very exciting so I'm
gonna move my mouse down and I feel like
I'm good because I have a process I wipe
myself down there it is I think that's
how we all feel
during the quarantine just to hit some
questions before we go Big Daddy jimmy
visa to hold the [ __ ] mic to your
mouth I know damn they're saying the
same thing this guy the totally deaf
sauces comments on Jane sama Bob Maul
brought the video game have you played
it I have I have lucky I was on it was
on Steam I played it on my twitch i
streamed it and it's it's fun it was
only the demo so I only got to a certain
level I got the fight LaForce
yeah man I heard he had two kills right
there was really awesome
Troy molar asks me is my is sports
jacket and homage to the Joker a little
bit when I saw it I was like purple how
many people could pull that off but so
far it's work I wore it all throughout
the reboot Roadshow tour I got a bunch
of jackets but this became kind of the
default I wondered on like Seth Meyers
and stuff so this became the new like
hooded sweatshirt or something like that
or the new hockey jersey okay
now everyone's happy because you're
putting your [ __ ] mic in your mouth
photo dude should get a tripod and read
I guess are you photo dude oh I see I'm
all right
no he's busy doing something man he's
got to run this whole thing all right
here we go man I didn't even get to see
no evil Mira said wait are you guys
ending we're just getting started evil
mirror yeah so what we're gonna do now
is read Holly weed yes
episode two is kind of like California
clerks if you will set in a weed store I
don't know if the pilot is still up on
YouTube but if it is you could see it
there
this would have been episode two being
read by me Kevin Smith Jason Mewes all
right here we go
Holly weed episode 2 Canadian Kush was
the title because I wrote the episode
for Cassie Steele we know Cassie steal
from the grass - grass eve de gracia the
next generation she played Manny Santos
from my favorite performances on that
show so I wrote this episode cuz always
wanted to put her in something and so I
wrote this episode with her in mind and
then the show didn't go anywhere
she's doing quite well right now Asafa
being voice on rick and morty
she's doing a voice for like a Disney
movie coming up like the lead character
and stuff into the microphone because
you've never podcast no I'm sorry you're
rusty you're so rusty yeah she was a
voice on Rick and Morty I'm not one of
the main family but she's she plays
Tammy the friend who cuz I had seen her
unlike these couple really like shows
where she was living in a house with
other people I don't know that was yeah
it was a CW show at one point where they
were living in a complex or someone yeah
it was called the complex I think haha
doodlee doodlee literally literally
literally Halloween days of the week
days of the week
alright here we go man Holly weed
episode 2 Canadian cush based on stories
by Donnell Rawlings and Kevin Smith
teleplay by Kevin Smith a second draft
July 12th
20:18 so a year and a half ago oh here
we go
interior la Cotte can you see what the
Sun and stuff yeah mine's a little like
Larry but I can still see
sorry guys yeah interior LA Confidential
that was the weed steward day pull out
from an extreme close-up on Rallo at the
far end of the counter he's staring off
camera while chowing down on some
expired edibles and then we go to Rallo
speedo v he's looking at nipsey that's
the character that donäôt plays down the
other end of the counter nipsey waits
out a female customer who can hear what
they're saying
Rallo watches and he's chewing then he
reaches into his shirt and he pulls out
a dirty old kids walkie-talkie
that he whispers in to Pete as my
character emerges from the back room
carrying a clear garbage can bag full of
weed for refilling he sees Rallo clock
and nipsey and he waves his hand in
front of Rallo his eyes to wake him Pete
says come on Rallo stop staring nips he
hates it when you ogle him you're an
ogre Oh GLE not ogre is that is that
[ __ ] over than me he's just
daydreaming nips cuz they all [ __ ] now
we got to explain I don't know if you
should stay Rollo for the whole scene
okay until Rollo leaves and I will
handle both karat love it okay alright
we'll start again so it's gonna be me as
Pete and then I'll also be doing
Darnell's lines it's nipsey but just for
this top scene Jay is Rallo only okay
come on Rallo stop starin nipsey hates
it when you ogle you're an ogre ovale
not ogre is that my [ __ ] ogling me
he's just daydreaming nips is this the
only thing you ate today no I ate before
I got here Peter Peter pumpkin eater you
know what I ate I hate that ass son I
did mine I ate him not cross buns I bust
my nuts while eatin but not bad
I'm gonna stop and jump in as a director
let's cut right there so it Hot Cross
Buns you probably can't see it because
the fire but it's meant to be a bit of a
little song so like I ate that ass son I
ate them hot cross buns
while the
and button then I you get codes alright
so here we go take two and I will lead
you in and action is this the only thing
you ate today
no I before I got here Peter Peter
pumpkin eater you know what I ate what I
ate that ass son I ate them not cross
buns I lost my nut Wow
eating button something like that as
Rallo sings pete rolls his eyes and
pulls money from his pocket he shoves it
into Rallo his hands to interrupt his
song he says oh that's fire ass is not a
balanced breakfast take this go next
door and get a burrito oh [ __ ] yeah man
I'm gonna buy some drugs no get a
burrito maybe some beans you need some
food with a little food in it man Rallo
exits the store staring in nipsey's
direction as he goes Nipsey J will now
be playing nipsey joins Pete was that
[ __ ] Oh Glenn me nobody was
ogling you man and how about you just
say staring at me like a normal person
oh I see what's going on here right I am
a man of color can't see big words huh
well apparently you can't see the words
like a parent let's try it again
let's try to get that line again and
we're gonna go take two I'll lead you in
with my line add action nobody was
ogling you and how about you just say
staring at me like a normal person oh I
see what's going on here a man of color
can't use big words
number one oval is not a big word number
two quit picking on the friendly
neighborhood homeless guy he he no real
homeless all right he lives next to our
dumpster nips I told you I saw him
driving a jeep at the Burbank target
that one's a jeep there's no way it was
Rollo dude you're blind Pete all right
yo you got to get another tourists
looking for some of that Holly weed
yeah and Pete heads over to the other
side of the counter to help the female
customer Jason Mewes now playing the
female customer I'm still Pete what God
do you for oh well you know what I am
looking for Holly weed but I don't see
it on the board oh we don't put it on
the board anymore because we could never
keep it in the store long enough [ __ ]
you're out of it yes but I got a secret
stash in the back how much you need
announced seriously you ever smoke Holly
weed
uh I invented Holly weed what you did
sorry that's acting right there
thank you you're like my god aw come on
look I took a hit at a party on Friday
and it was the best [ __ ] I ever smoked
in my life man I got buck wild and
[ __ ] a total stranger whoa I don't
know is that good oh it's amazing man it
makes my ass wet mop and you made that
[ __ ] [ __ ] I feel like I'm dead talking
to a celebrity right now oh I'm no
celebrity I'm just playing old pot store
Pete well hello Peter you're a genius
oh stop it I'm just a guy trying to
blaze his own Trail so to speak like a
Lois and Clark of weed well maybe not
maybe just the Lois Clark was kind of an
[ __ ] [ __ ] Clark now I think about it
well maybe a trailblazer like he needs a
guide on your expedition she leans on
the counter I can be here I'll help you
out with this the term from history
Sacagawea I can be your second Julia and
I can lead you to the Pacific and then
she fake whispers into my my mother do a
lot of several canoes and into my page
nice Pete chuckles nervously struggling
to say something then she says your meat
makes me want to do the dirty you want
to do the dirty like every day I want to
do the dirty hell yeah well then how
about we get high as kites and you let
me [ __ ] you okay how how tight is your
[ __ ] Pete huh how tight is your
[ __ ] uh I don't it's not there oh let
me let me jump in it's this is a term
for mathematics I believe Pythagorean
theory it's not the pipe pipe Aaron
Pythagorean it's not the pipe Gary a [ __ ]
Rhian like I'm gonna take a piss on this
aggregate Pythagorean it's not the piss
gariand it's not to pick there Ian
theorem how tight is your stupid little
[ __ ] what are you talking about Nick
see it creeps up behind a baffle Pete
and
slaps him on the ass Wow
Pete startles whoo here we go you guys
stay the girl okay okay so nipsey comes
in slaps Peter that's pow Pete startles
nipsey and the female customer high-five
is that crack up laughing Pete has lost
his [ __ ] if it says oh [ __ ]
peg boy Pete gonna get his ass [ __ ] by
a Canadian girl what the [ __ ] man old
girls are comic I know from the improv
this is Chilliwack Collins sorry he made
me do it I've never known the Canadian
people to be so deceptive they're not
I'm just an outlier very good no you're
an outlaw she's an illegal Pete ooh come
to America and taking our jobs all day
whenever I'm not taking the piss at a
gullible old man I'm sorry old yo
Chili's got a set tonight she asked if
we want to go I would but I'm broke all
right look how about I put you on the
guest list I'd be all aboot that thank
you [ __ ] you we don't say a bhoot you
just literally set a boot like you were
one of the Degrassi kids which is a very
funny joke because it would have been a
former Degrassi kid funny to me what the
[ __ ] are you talking about you did it
again
a boots adorable man he turns to nips he
goes you heard it am i right sniffs he
goes that shit's racist son and then it
turns to chili says I'm sorry about my
redneck friend I say redneck I'm from
New Jersey and he goes maybe South
Jersey like the cousin [ __ ] Deep
South Jersey stereotyping [ __ ]
and then he walks away and we put up the
title card
Halle weed all right in exterior LA
Confidential at night we see the gate is
closed the open sign in the window goes
off exterior LA Confidential back alley
same time Pete and nipsey emerge from
the back door I'll be Pete Jay will be
nipsey whose driving mirror you to the
improv oh hey sorry do the improv it
look dude it's a couple blocks let's
walk walk who am i Michael Phelps he's a
[ __ ] swimmer dummy he's the first
sports person I could think of point is
I'm not taking my car all right sir
drive Miss Daisy
just get us a good table when you get
there and you buy the first round as
Pete nods and runs off Nipsey digs into
his pockets looking for keys when he
can't find him he realizes they're
inside he tries the door handle but it's
already locked
Nipsey then peers through the window and
he sees the keys they're on a stool by
the door locked inside an irritated nips
he tries to door handle again it's still
locked he pulls a credit card from his
wallet looks around then slips it into
the window opening the lock he slides
the window open and hops up climbing
halfway in as his legs dangle from the
window a cop car stops in the alley cop
1 and cop 2 look from the legs to each
other
interior LA Confidential back entrance
night nipsey has struggled halfway
through the tiny window when police
lights ignite behind him in a siren
briefly blasts nipsey startles exterior
The Improv night establishing shot of
the world-famous comedy club on Melrose
interior improv entry st. Pete stands in
a line behind two girls the girls are
met in the doorway by a bouncer he's
holding up locking pouches that's what
he put dear phones in at a comedy club
I'll be two bouncer you'd be two girls
okay you got a cell phone if she's got a
pole she's got a cell phone one of the
comics is trying out new material so
we're using the locking pouches tonight
put your cell phone in here you can't
make me put my phone in that thing we
have rights this is America this is the
Improv and at The Improv tonight
everybody's got to bag their cell phones
this is not East Germany I'm not locking
up my mobile I ain't talking about your
mobile and talk about your cell phone
and if you don't give me your cell phone
you can just get the [ __ ] back in and
the into your mobile and drive the [ __ ]
away [ __ ] you Donald Trump who the
[ __ ] Donald Trump Pete says I think
he's one of the comedians on the show
tonight bouncer says well I never heard
of him you got a cell phone
Pete says I do and it's a mobile let me
just turn it off to save the battery
bouncer locks the phone and the pouch it
says we unlock the pouch when you leave
or if you got some kind of emergency and
then Pete says an emergency
no way man I'm crazy unreliable nobody's
ever calling me in case of an emergency
exterior LA Confidential back alley
night nipsey's trying to call Pete and
he says help me Pete it's an emergency
he races off as he's chased by two cops
with flash flashlights interior main
room night the MC riffs for a beat and
then says okay put your hands together
for a funny little lady from Canada
Chile Collins Chile takes the stage
pulling the mic off the stand the
audience applause as does Pete who's
sitting at a table alone he looks toward
the door for a sign and nipsey then it
goes back to watching Chile so you mean
you [ __ ] up my intro you're supposed
to say put your hands together for a
funny little lady with the huge vagina
from Canada or else people confuse me
with Russell Peters that's a very funny
Canadian comics joke if you're remotely
into the Canadian comic scene back to
Jeff who has a tight vagina by the way
you could bounce a quarter off his [ __ ]
Pete in the audience crack up as chili
stalks the stage okay okay so I met this
guy and he's older right not old enough
to be my dad but old enough to blow my
dad now if that makes any sense okay so
let me go again we're gonna go take to
it so you were in the right spirit of
things here we go and action okay
playing a girl actually okay so I met
this guy and he's older not old enough
to be my dad but old enough to blow my
dad if that makes any sense anyway I
kind of like him I kind of like this guy
so I tell him how about we get high as
kites and I [ __ ] you and he's all like
uh uh yeah so and and he's all like and
how tight is your [ __ ] and he's like
what and I'm like how tight is your
stupid little [ __ ] because if I'm
gonna strap on a rubber dick and [ __ ]
you I at least want to know the size of
the dildo to bring like I can wear a
rectum record thick as a can of coke and
twice as bad for you but I only busted
out on really really special occasions
cuz it's a family heirloom that was
passed down to me from my mom and for my
grandmother and
think that he'd be all like Bob [ __ ]
but he wasn't he was like oh wait can i
watch that wheel of fortune while you do
it such a creepy little [ __ ] loser
man I'm still gonna [ __ ] him tonight but
he's such a creepy [ __ ] loser
audience loves chili pizza little
smitten as well being the butt of the
joke exterior The Improv back-alley
night Pete and chilly emerge the bouncer
is out back now so wait I'll play
bouncer you'd be bouncers long Pete
bouncers well you'd be the girl Pete
says chilly you killed up there man you
were like George Carlin good I loved it
Pete holds up his phone pouch to the
voucher up to the bouncer for unlock and
he says Free Tibet then the bouncer says
everybody thinks they're a [ __ ]
comedian around here night Shep yo you
crushed it kick Canada that's what the
bouncer says thanks chef chilly turns to
face Pete for a beat then simply says
okay good night chilly walks away before
confused Pete could say goodbye after a
beat she turns and calls out to Pete I'm
kidding Oh cuz I was gonna say you want
to get something need sure Pete catches
up to chili and they start walking where
do you want to go
how about Jerry's in the valley man they
got these Pizza bread sticks that are
mazing after they closed the Jerry's on
Beverly Pete casually takes Chili's hand
as they walk chili pulls it away in a
defensive almost hostile action just try
to hold my [ __ ] hand I did [ __ ] oh
I'm sorry is that bad oh my god I'm so
embarrassed I thought it was because you
were up on stage you were saying like
you were gonna [ __ ] sleep with me so I
look I make some jokes as a comedy at a
comedy club and that makes you think
it's cool to rape me in a back alley hey
what the [ __ ] me too me too me too I'm
getting me to Dover here what the hell
man you cannot silence me man time is up
for you and all your [ __ ] frat bros
that bros I'm 47
suddenly chilli starts giggling she
pushes the mortified Pete playfully I'm
just [ __ ] kidding Pete got your [ __ ]
you see what I just did
funny [ __ ] Canada right so how come this
guy's not chilly turns back to see Pete
sneaking away hey oh god what if you're
done toying with me I'd like to go home
and cry
now maybe eat my feelings with some cake
maybe call my mom and tell her how her d
los angeles could be no no Peter Peter
its fighting I just crushed it at the
improv Chile links arms with Pete like
they're off to see the Wizard
[ __ ] food I say we go back to your store
and get baked Pete struggles to react
Chile puts on a pouty face what's the
matter don't you think I'm cute Pete I
mean yes so I can't tell if you're
[ __ ] with me again Chile rolls her
eyes and walks away a few steps then she
stops turns and returns to Pete saying
look my heart literally skipped a beat
when you took my hand so she holds out
her hand now I'm asking you to hold mine
Pete is touched man he goes to take
chile san and she pulls it away laughing
Pete heads down the alley burn you're so
[ __ ] me and you're like Lucy with the
[ __ ] football no no I'm like
peppermint patty cuz I got a friend
named Marcie and I constantly eat her
[ __ ] just as they're about to turn the
corner and out of you chilli finally
takes Pete's hand exterior LA
Confidential night the store is closed
the steel gate is down interior LA
Confidential st. Pete and chilly enter
through the back door they approach the
counter in the dark yeah it's a little
dark in here Mole Man that's why God
gave his cellphones been huh my shits
off and nipsey says mine's not and he's
got his phone light in his face Pete and
chilli freak out and if she turns the
store lights on pizzas Jesus snip snip
she says I've been calling your ass all
night Pete why'd you turn your phone off
I said The Improv put my phone in one of
those lock bags holy [ __ ] 37 messages
why didn't you just come to the Improv
and if she says cuz I was in jail
[ __ ] I'm Pete Angela chili say
what and that's will will stop reading
the script it makes sense right
look if hanger action yeah we're halfway
through there's 15 more pages to go yeah
so we get to do it again
some of the time how was that into the
microphone you [ __ ] sorry Jesus I
bring a [ __ ] pro with me and he's
just like
[Music]
sorry I uh I was good read for a guy
that like [ __ ] you never saw that
before no totally cold read
thank you I felt like I could have done
a little better switching up the the I
would like to get I need to get better
at trying to focus on a character and
then switching over a little bit of a
different voice like I would like to
play the girl a little this and then if
I was playing nipsey this way and I
think you're entirely too hard on
yourself
thank you i I think we should do like
you know reading with Jane Paul we just
did it well no I know but I mean I think
we feel like I got an idea let's read a
script my awesome if we like continue to
do it like even if it's you know if it's
once look that's all we got is [ __ ]
reading scripts and talking to each
other because we're not like John
Krasinski starters show on YouTube
called good news or whatever some good
news and it's like all famous people
it's like it's Steve Carell it's
lin-manuel it's how are they did talking
today actually coming in person are they
facetiming they're all you know in
separate rooms he's like in this in a
room with his wife Emily Blunt so they
could be together they're you know they
share space yeah but everyone else I
think like kind of you know zooms in or
whatever oh I see what you're getting at
you're like we're brave we can't well
too late we've been we've been online
for a while man you don't have to like
you don't have to if I could pass on any
advice to you stop [ __ ] racing
against John Krasinski your whole life
just don't we won't win he's winning
already no that wasn't my thoughts got a
huge they've got quiet place to coming
out whenever we're [ __ ] out of
lockdown no no no I wasn't thinking that
I was thinking that that's Krasinski's
helicopter right now
shut the [ __ ] up I was thinking about
here's some good news shut the [ __ ] up
people are interacting with other people
I know there's a you know different
options and a lot of Morse code I see a
lot of people on YouTube doing
old-school Morse code to each other some
I dig it dig the whole thing I wish you
know I will shake I had more time
literally all we have right now you're
like burgess Meredith in that Twilight
Zone episode II like I wish I had more
time and there's nobody left on earth
you're surrounded by books and you break
a glass I can't just go away and leave
the wife don't take care of Logan all
day like I can't go on my back room and
stream for ten hours you could it just
wouldn't be good for your marriage no
were you or being a dad kid will wind up
on a therapist couch years from now
going like you know where he was during
the [ __ ] quarantine streaming and his
mancave me and mom fending for ourselves
having to [ __ ] pull vegetables out of
the earth to feed ourselves he was no
[ __ ] help but all I can go over
[ __ ] uncle Kevin's house read a silly
ass script hate my father we we actually
planted a garden it's we have a nice
little garden gum or do you think you
know what do you grow good time to do
some strawberries strawberry strawberry
yeah we got strawberries mint I mean
there's all these things honestly Jordan
planted all the pieces and got him but
cucumbers
I think she's half the audience just
dropped out as you do your [ __ ]
garden list cause you got carrots [ __ ]
this I'm gonna watch John Krasinski show
[ __ ] you that's why you'll won't be a
craze in ski man while I'm going like we
got fruit trying to dig in a guy's
vegetables roots on we've got rabbits
you'll see when you're calling us up
going hey can I get a [ __ ] strawberry
son with no food I'm like we're dying
over here and be a [ __ ] strong
[ __ ] whip around the deck I'll suck
your dick first job ferryman how
what's the timeout here how long did it
take the reader script was it 15 pages
we only read 15 and there was a long
talk up into it no it's great you uh
we're gonna get ready to get out of here
but Jay isn't going nowhere Jay is gonna
literally sit here and game on my deck
even though just a few seconds ago he
was like I can't leave Jordan with the
kid he's literally gonna sit here and
game in the open air on the deck oh the
Sun comes down behind me that's right
till there's no more light whatsoever
until he's just lit by his computer
screen um what's your twitch name its
Jay Mewes JY mewa yes if you don't
twitch app already it's free to download
you can just and you just look for my
name you give what are you gonna be
doing with the twitch kids today so I'm
gonna play some some games I'm either
gonna play apex or fortnight I just got
to see what is ready to go here cuz
again there's downloads and updates
constantly so I'm gonna play that game
and I'll be on for like another hour so
I think it was a weird tease that we
showed this the whole time and never
once played it well nether aascend
we're gonna get to this I also would
love to do what's in the box I've been
seeing another version of it again yeah
what's in the box was a show that's on
our YouTube channel that we did years
ago and basically we opened a box and
there was cool stuff inside and we
commented on it we could do a modern-day
version of that what's in that box we're
essentially we get all sorts of viruses
and see if it's the one that we're all
scared of and stuff ah I'm all I'm all
for up for doing anything man as long as
you come here and [ __ ] I'm going over
there ground zero five-year-old
that's like germ central we're here it's
beautiful that's a more separated yeah I
love it six feet if you start doing it
more often we're I'm gonna get like you
know they now at the grocery store is
that the glass shield like at the thing
they're really yeah so when you you're
at the teller they have a gosh you
trying to tell me you're gonna get a
[ __ ] spit guard for me sneeze guard
fair enough
I see where I rank no don't forget folks
to wash your hands
stuff don't forget when you wear gloves
it doesn't necessarily mean you're safe
cross-contamination is a real thing so
take your gloves off wash your [ __ ]
hands and stuff like that and don't
listen of [ __ ] famous people or quasi
famous people when they tell you what to
do except in this instance wash your
[ __ ] hands please if you're in the
New Jersey area Thursday night as where
we're from New Jersey in Middletown New
Jersey in Monmouth County Thursday night
is takeout night man support all your
local Jersey Middletown Jersey eateries
man named them name and eatery from old
school the Middletown diner
probably yeah we got Francesco's and
Highlands New Jersey I mean probably
whoever it is the list of all the names
but we're if you're in the area sorry I
wasn't paying attention I thought you
just said name some cool restaurants in
Jersey that's right I started naming off
stuff my bed is like Katz's pork roll
egg and cheese there it is folks enjoy
man try to fight that boredom make some
stuff yourselves and if you really like
this will come back read the second half
from the script until then man how do we
how do we normally end the show it's
been so long I hope you had a good time
everyone have a good time I can't thank
you enough for coming out tonight but
there is no show without the guys
sitting to my left gives up for mr.
Jason Mewes and that is Jay and Silent
Bob get old for this week I'm Kevin
Smith wait go to my chapter again I did
a sign on and stuff we're gonna move
over and when you go to his twitch he's
gonna start right off the bat by telling
you how long he's been clean and sober
yeah there's a [ __ ] hand off that's
right you're like wait it ain't Jade's
on Bob get old unless you find out how
long he's been clean sober you gonna do
that on his twitch Oh
so that's James Audubon for this week
I'm Kevin Smith cue music go get old
everybody good night
you